ich habe mich unfassbar schutzlos und
benutzt gefühlt also man fragt sich dann
was macht dieser mann mit den aufnahmen
so befriedigt er sich selbst dazu
stellte die vielleicht sogar ins
internet und andere befriedigen sich
dazu
[Musik]
ich würde zwei mal opfer von ups körting
aber mit 13 auf einer klassenfahrt
wohnen lehrer an einer anderen schule
mädchen unter die röcke gefilmt hat und
einem auf dem festival mit 16 hat mich
eine freundin darauf aufmerksam gemacht
dass mir ein mann gerade den kamera
zwischen die beine hält ich bin zur
polizei gegangen
die hat sich doch für mich wirklich
interessiert
ich war unfassbar wütend als ich das
gemerkt habe und habe den mann direkt
darauf angesprochen und erst dann auch
wütend geworden und hat gesagt er hätte
kein foto gemacht und ist sogar fast
handgreiflich geworden
wir fordern dass ups körting da und
losing es hätte also fotos in den
intimbereich filmaufnahmen in den
mädchenbereich in deutschland unter
strafe gestellt werden
ich habe immer können petition gestartet
gegen abstürze und begleitet seitdem mit
einer freundin zusammen für pressearbeit
und natürlich versuchen mit politikern
und politikerinnen darüber zu sprechen
wir sind heute vom
bundesjustizministerium und zugegeben
verdammt recht über 100 1400 5000
unterschriften haben deutlich gemacht
wie sehr dieses thema in der
gesellschaft
[Musik]
ich habe von mir von der petition des
abgehörten strafe wird und die
gesellschaft sensibilisiert wird für
dieses thema und die betroffenen endlich
ernst genommen werden wenn jemand sagt
das ist total überspitzt thema mal nicht
so ein ding raus nehme ich das nicht
wirklich ernst weil ich weiß dass die
problematik weiters wurde mit so vielen
betroffenen geschrieben haben die hass
kommentare sind jetzt zum teil viel viel
härter aber die lese ich mir auch gar
nicht durch ich möchte da auch gar
nichts daraus zitieren weil ich den gar
keine plattform bieten will
für das was die uns schreiben das geht
uns ja das ist uns eigentlich egal